dude matsuya's my favorite place on
earth the best why don't you wanna do
you wanna explain matzia
so there's like three like beef bowls
it's the big three
the basically the big the big three of
like beef bowls and just general like
meat and rice yeah
fast food chains so there's matsuya
[Music]
the vlog channels be like go to
yoshinoya like no don't go to yoshinoya
let me tell you why matsia is the best
straight
first of all you have to speak to people
i don't like that
right you have to like tell the person
what you want i'm not for that i like it
when the machine
takes my order and i give the the man
the ticket i don't say anything
yeah yeah get my meal right right right
i love that first of all because it's an
english option
as well not that like you know
everything should have an english option
i'm not here for that i'm just saying
that
it's nice that i don't have to worry
when i'm eating because sometimes in
japan
you're just like [ __ ] man i just want to
order without having to [ __ ] myself
like japan japan makes it like a lot of
places in japan make it very easy just
to not have human interaction
yeah which i appreciate so which as a
british person
that's fan [ __ ] tastic what i hate
though
also as a british person in any
restaurant in japan if they don't have a
button
that calls the waiter to you you have to
call them yourself
and so in england the etiquette is that
you try to be as quiet as possible you
you like look for eye contact okay you
look
like excuse me yeah yeah even the hand
hand is a risky move
oh yeah you even the hand you're kind of
making a scene there in britain yeah
yeah yeah
it's kind of just it's like it's a lot
of this like yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah like you want the
bill it's like uh
okay and that's as much as that's as
much as you do to get
a waiter's attention in japan you gotta
shout out you gotta shout out the top of
your lungs
koreans are like laughing their ass off
right now they're like these peasants
but the worst part is is that like me
and gone will go like i'll go like full
volume like sumacer
and the silence yeah
they're like coming over the speed of
light i'm like what the [ __ ] i don't get
that because like the other
like last week we went to like an
izakaya afterwards like after we
finished recording
and because it's there's a guy that
doesn't have the button so yeah conor
mcgregor just like oh
with this [ __ ] again it's like so
fulfilling prophecy the moment you sit
down right
it's like i know that it's okay to shout
publicly like to get their attention
yeah like my body has been like
crafted yeah overlapping it's
conditioned yeah should
never ever ever make any public
disturbance it's the same in australia
so like i remember like the first couple
of years i lived here like i never did
it
yeah i always just kind of just did this
like a lot of the eye contact like
naughty thing
because in japan they just don't want to
make eye contact they do everything to
avoid eye contact so doing that's
impossible so
every time i have to shut out i die a
little bit yeah i think my life
expectancy goes down by a few months
every time i said
and especially if it fails yeah but then
have you ever had the the pity one where
i've said it like summerson and then
they won't ignore me but one of the
customers will have heard me
yeah and he'll go like so am i saying
and they like point at me
he wants he wants your attention
white as [ __ ] dude he's like i'll help
the foreigner out i'll give him a dub
but anyway back to matsuya the best
place in japan
you basically can get like a banger of a
meal that fills you up to like the brim
for like eight bucks maybe like less if
you want to get the cheaper ones
like even less like there's a the set i
go for it's like you get this like oh
it's amazing this grilled ginger pork
and like rice you get a potato salad you
got a ton judo which is like miso soup
with extra [ __ ] in it yeah that's
amazing i [ __ ] love that [ __ ] yeah
but like you can get like a regular like
beef ball with all of that for like 600
yeah like like nothing if you want to go
ham you can get it and like you can like
less than 10 bucks you can like double
that [ __ ] up as well off like an
additional like two bucks and it's like
a whole pig
it's like amazing i love it like every
time i come in like [ __ ] connor's coming
in get the get the whole pig carcass out
like because i'm like max everything
because i'm like i want
meat and rice i'm there it's so good
and yo you get these like pathetic
little bowl sizes like what am i going
to do
okay okay are good i just think
manchester is like the best
oh yeah yeah yeah but like you go but
that's because you don't order like what
they specialize in
no you get like the side menu [ __ ] right
yeah i mean yeah i guess
because in terms of like actual like
beef balls like udons like i i reckon
ski
and yoshinoya have it better than
matsuya man
just saying oh we can go we're going to
make a [ __ ] japanese fast food tier
list here
for that we should do a video of one of
the you can go
you can go gosh yeah and i'll be like
this is what you get we just argue
which one's the best we'll take each
other to each chain and then we'll be
like this is what we're getting this is
the best one yeah
i remember this one time um i i went to
this
very like local place in sydney because
this is when we were staying outside of
japan
no not not outside outside of tokyo yeah
so it's a bit more in the countryside
um so we went in this like what we were
craving ramen so we were looking for
like a
like a local ramen place and we go to
this place um obviously
neither of us can you know speak
japanese or read it too well
so we go to this place and the entire
menu is handwritten in kanji
oh yeah and so we love that because i've
learned the kanji with the numbers i'm
like
big brain no but like we had to kind of
try to figure out what everything is
and so we we go we we pick
something that's you know looks
reasonable because we
look we were looking at the price and
the price was about 1300 yen which is
about 13 bucks
forgetting that in japan like
ramen is cheap super super cheap and we
were ordering something that was like
13 bucks when he should have in the
middle of nowhere yeah in the middle of
nowhere should be like 7 800 yeah
when it should be about 7 800 yen um and
we forgot that
and i remember we we ordered it and
the waiter just looks at us and i think
he was asking are you sure
he was are you sure you want this you
want this one two of them
and we were like you should have known
that yeah yeah did we just want some
was like we just won ramen yeah we want
it and so he he goes back he says
something to
he says something to the uh chef and the
chef's
eyes just goes okay
oh you you seriously like seriously
so what comes out is they bring us this
like extra large
ramen and then with it was just this
extra large beef bowl
he brings out one of them puts it in
front of me and i just think
i've made a massive mistake i look at
sydney sydney's just staring at this
ball being like that
so he sees like we order two of those
two to one each
because it would be impossible for one
of us to finish this let alone
uh uh two of us finishing both of them
yeah and
so so we bring it out and he brings he
brings it over to sydney and i don't
know what the etiquette is if you don't
finish your food
but we we [ __ ] try to devour as much
as we can we don't even get through half
of it
we feel we feel so [ __ ] bad
we we're getting the bill it was the
most shameful bill of all time
we didn't even make a [ __ ] dent in
this oh my god i've never experienced
that because like i would rather like
like behead myself than leave food in a
japanese thing i don't know why i'm so
scared of it like one time in matzia
funnily enough
i accidentally ordered two of like the
double l size sets
right which is like way too much food
it's like i think it's near 4 000
calories
like it is like a mountain of rice and
and i don't know how i actually did this
i should have realized by how much i
paid
and it came and i was like [ __ ] i wasn't
even that hungry
i was like [ __ ] so i i like forced this
inside of me
yeah i i was like when i got home i
threw up
but like in the restaurant i was like if
you could imagine
like a dude literally like if his
esophagus was full i was literally like
like drinking miso soup to like push it
down you know what i mean i was like
give me more water i need to push this
[ __ ] down with water
it was it was horrible i thought i was
going to die he must have been looking
at me like me crying in a matter
why is he why is he still eating it
that's like the most
british thing i've ever heard would
rather throw up from eating too much
food than feel the shame of leaving food
on the planet you'd rather throw up
in like an alleyway than like like order
way too much clearly
and then you have to give them it back
and be like throw it away yeah yeah
like yeah okay was it very unhealthy and
extremely questionable but yeah but
you know sometimes you have to make a
decision but i got the respect from
those muscles but when i said gotcha
i [ __ ] meant that
i've never eaten that much food in my
life